welcome to Hannity buckle up tonight the
Democratic party is officially yeah
we'll call it a dumpster fire or
far-left radicalism spinning in a
thousand different directions clamoring
for impeachment fantasies more subpoena
stuns and of course far left socialism
the likes of which would destroy this
country while now tonight the president
he is standing strong against his
never-ending harassment and he now is
vowed to fight every single step in the
way the right thing to do we have full
coverage just ahead but first operation
crossfire hurricane is now officially
morphed into crossfire boomerang for the
Clintons the Democrats and all these
deep state actors that abuse power now
the spotlight shines brighter on her
bought and paid for
Russian lies along with major new
developments tonight surrounding the
notorious email server yes involving
Barack Obama yes Anthony Weiner we're
gonna give you all the details we start
with an even bigger development of the
tinfoil hat conspiracy media mob what
they haven't told you about because we
are learning from the Washington
Examiner tonight Robert Muller's report
contains a claim that Russians recorded
then President Bill Clinton having phone
sex with Monica Lewinsky back in the
1990s Wow
the explosion allegedly reportedly is in
the redacted report released to the
public not there but it's in the
redacted section according to sources
talking to an examiner the redaction
comes on page 109 of bolos report and
references a meeting between Jared
Kushner and a Russian publisher where he
detailed this claim and remember Ken
Starr in in his 1998 report identified
at least 17 phone sex calls conversation
between 1996 and 97 and wrote the
President Clinton quote suspected that a
foreign embassy was tapping his
telephone but he did it anyway even
proposing quote cover stories to
Lewinsky if it turned out they were
actually being monitored now so far the
special counsel the Department of
Justice they're refusing to comment but
wouldn't it be something year of the
boomerang operation boomerang
hurricane after all the media hysteria
surrounding Trump and Russia and stormy
stormy stormy the lies the conspiracy
theories the phony dossier uranium one
that it was the Clintons who were
totally compromised all along and
everything they were accusing Trump of
was actually true about them and we
already know the Clinton campaign were
the ones colluding with the Russians yes
they paid for a dirty steel dossier yeah
Oh with Russian lies Hillary she was the
one that used the private secret server
that put our national security at risk
we believe six foreign intelligence
agencies hacked into that and even now
the story is taking a bigger turn
according to Judicial Watch former
senior FBI official bill pre-snap
admitted under oath in court order
discovery that the agency found Clinton
email records from her private server in
the Obama White House specifically the
executive office that's right of
President Obama now again we asked what
did Obama know and when did he know it
we're the first to ask it we do need an
answer the story doesn't stop there
because we also have confirmation
tonight
that nearly 49,000 Clinton emails were
found on Anthony Weiner's laptop and who
wants to guess they all warned about
grandkids yoga a wedding and a funeral
she claimed so what does this all mean
that Barack Obama now appears to be more
firmly implicated in the Clinton's email
scheme than previously thought member
they talked about well one high-ranking
administration official we know Obama
emailed Hillary on a private server and
the great irony in all this is that
Hillary still thinks she did nothing
wrong
but is she sure that President Trump oh
yeah she's certain he obstructed justice
you can't make this up take a look
any other person who had engaged in
those acts would certainly have been
indicted but because of the the rule in
the Justice Department that you can't
indict a sitting president as I read it
basically what I thought it was saying
is look we think he obstructed justice
here
eleven examples of why we think he
obstructed justice but we're under the
control of the Justice Department and
their rule is you can't indict Wow now
Clinton doubled down on her delusion and
an op-ed published earlier today in the
Washington Post writing quote Congress
can't forget that the issue today is not
just the president's possible
obstruction of justice it's hard
national security
really now before calling for a new
Commission to guard against further
cyber attacks because quote the
President of the United States has
proved himself unwilling to defend our
nation from a clear and present danger
how could any one individual be this out
of touch or this disconnected from
reality now first off Hillary the
Attorney General made the determination
along with the office of legal counsel
rod Rosenstein without even considering
as you said whether or not you can
indict a sitting president that
determination was made without that that
the evidence did not support any charge
of obstruction oh by the way no
underlying crime like your case now this
directly from the Attorney General quote
our determination was made without
regard to and is not based on the
constitutional considerations that
surround the indictment and criminal
prosecution of a sitting president if
you want to talk about any other person
let's talk about your obstruction
Hillary your violation of the Espionage
Act you're putting America's national
security at risk remember we have
overwhelming incontrovertible evidence
of your mishandling of top-secret
classified information on a private
server even Comey admitted you had it
and remember top FBI lawyer James Baker
general counsel at the FBI thought you
should be indicted is incontrovertible
evidence of obstruction why did you
destroy 33,000 emails and then bleach
fit the harddrive and destroy the
smartphones with hammers and remove the
SIM cards oh that means intent the
intent was to get rid of the evidence
because of the underlying crime the
Espionage Act 18 USC 793 of course the
media ignores all this the corruption
the abuse of power what is a two-tier
justice
system.this don't forget about all the
other clinton corruption involving
russia remember bill cash again hey on
moscow speeches during the iranian one
deal twice his fee hillary signed off on
that deal the kickbacks from the people
involved in that deal one hundred and
forty five million dollars even while it
was known putin had thugs in america we
had a spy in his in his reign in america
remember
we interviewed a william campbell
bribery extortion money laundering
kickbacks trying to get a foothold in
our uranium market william campbell was
on this show he exposed it that's real
collusion and that's real obstruction of
justice which will have more of in a
minute as we turn to our hannity media
watch reality check now with no
credibility left to lose oh the media
mob their lies exposed and they
avalanche a truth cascading down in the
days weeks and months ahead so what do
they do
they're actually patting themselves on
the back for their great coverage of
Trump and Russia it were wrong so often
almost every day and they ignored the
biggest abuse of power the biggest story
they could have ever had in their life
but we were here doing their job for
them take a look I can't imagine that
we'll ever do anything harder than that
so proud of our coverage NBC is I mean
it's the best of the best the other
thing this report did is that it really
corroborated a lot of the good
journalism that was done time and again
in this Moeller report reporting from
major news outlets is confirmed in the
smaller report as being accurate how did
that guy just get an awards and a book
deal love each they love themselves they
have no capacity for introspection
self-reflection self-criticism
accountability how many times on this
show have we exposed over and over and
over again there lies the conspiracy
theories list after list fake news story
after fake news story all the all-stars
at their worst
now where's the media there they're
really going to lose this whole thing in
all this soon we will have more
closed-door testimony
coming out proving we've been right all
along they've been wrong we'll have the
Attorney General bar now has said he's
launched an investigation into spying
into the Trump campaign and all matters
surrounding the investigation a
witch-hunt against the sitting president
criminal referrals from congressman
Nunez the Horowitz oh yeah the FISA
investigation it's gonna be interesting
Hillary's Russian bought and paid for
lies yeah
the 302s leaking intelligence unmasking
Americans also look what they did to
Carter page spies Stefan halper checking
in on Clovis page and Papadopoulos all
these things that were obtained using
Hillary's bought and paid for dossier
never verified never corroborated
created according to the New York Times
this week it might have all been one big
dissing Formation campaign and we'll
also get gang of eight information now
whether the media mob likes this or not
this Avalanche is real and truth and
justice are coming and all will be held
accountable especially with the
president who is standing strong and
fighting back against the Democrats they
can't let it go now after the president
was the most cooperative president in
history
now once ever invoking executive
privilege he did have the right under
Article two to fire Muller Rosen Stein
could have done it in just because he
said oh these people are horrible need
to be fired he didn't do it did he looks
like they talked about secretly
recording a president invoking the 25th
amendment they thought about and talked
about it didn't do it now with their
latest being of course in Congress their
bid to bring in former White House
Counsel Dom McGann for Terry why was he
ever allowed to talk for 30 hours in the
first place I don't get that that was an
executive privilege moment listen to the
president earlier today he's fighting
back well the subpoena is ridiculous we
have been I have been the most
transparent president and administration
in the history of our country by far we
just went through the Muller witch-hunt
where you had really 18 angry Democrats
at a president Trump they ate him with a
bad thing
they were contributors in many cases to
a Clinton aide up with a passion how
they picked this panel I don't know and
they came up with no collusion and they
actually also came up with no
obstruction but we're fighting all the
subpoenas look these aren't like
impartial people the Democrats are
trying to win 20/20 they're not going to
win with the people that I see it's like
we've been telling you on this program
Democrats their cohorts they're willing
accomplices the media mob they will stop
at nothing to make every waking moment
of public trial against Donald Trump
and anyone who likes Donald Trump
swelling smelly wall more people like us
irredeemable deplorable we cling to God
our guns our Bibles religion Wow okay
that's what you think of the American
people the heart and soul of this
country no concern for the law doctrine
executive privilege Constitution facts
reality they push collusion hysteria for
three years four times now four times no
collusion no concern with any agenda to
make this country better more safe more
prosperous no more secure you just want
to continue to fight the president every
minute every second of every day on
anything because you're consumed with
your anti-trump rage you've ignored you
idiots the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal in our nation's
history and you've ignored an effort to
take down a duly elected president and
rigging an investigation into a
political candidate and trying to rig a
2016 election you ignored the most
pressing issues that are facing this
country everything for the economy
foreign policy diplomacy the safety and
security and our borders for crying out
loud
bringing us tonight to a Hannity watch
on the southern border there is a total
system meltdown and it's real and it's
not manufactured illegal immigration is
surging Border Patrol had near record
apprehensions in March a US border
personnel they are overwhelmed drug
traffickers cartels human traffickers
they are exploiting this weakness of not
having a wall hour-by-hour look at this
new footage from border patrol showing
heavily armed men taking migrants across
our border
lighting what we have been saying for
months frankly years on the show strong
border security first a wall first
it makes people on both sides safer no
one should have to go through this we
need to ensure the safety of the
security of the country first and also
protect those migrants who are being
exploited by evil people and traffic
through Central America and Mexico and
the horrible crimes committed oftentimes
along the way we have to hold foreign
governments accountable thankfully we
have a president continuing to get that
message and he's not giving up the fight
he tweeted a response to a report about
Mexican soldiers pulling guns on our
National Guard really better not happen
again the president said we're now
sending armed soldiers to the border in
Mexico it's not doing nearly enough in
apprehending and returning now the
crisis is real it's intensifying and I
think in large part because well in
Central America and Mexico they actually
believe the president they see the wall
being built and the repairs being made
and the president now has the money